well now to the latest on that framework
deal for gun reform in Washington which
just got some major help on the
Republican side Senate minority leader
Mitch McConnell says he supports the
proposals hashed out by a bipartisan
group of senators but a bill based on
that deal still hasn't been written
Nicole Killian is following it all on
Capitol Hill Nicole good morning hey
good morning to you Michelle leader
McConnell said he is comfortable with
this agreement and said if it holds he
will support this legislation McConnell
joins at least 10 other Senate
Republicans who have already backed the
framework it boosts mental health and
school safety funding enhances
background checks for gun buyers under
21 and provides Financial incentives for
states to pass red flag laws to remove
guns from people who could pose a danger
Democratic and Republican negotiators
are currently drafting the legislation
and hope the bill can be finalized this
week their goal is to hold a vote in the
Senate next week before Congress
recesses for the July 4th holiday Tony
all right Nicole got it thank you very
much